in how many ways can a circle and a
straight line lie on a plane one way
would be like this where they don't meet
at all another way is like this where
they meet at exactly one point such
lines are called tangents a line which
meets a circle at exactly one point is
called the tangent and the third way in
which it can meet the circle is like
this at two points it's called a secant
one point tangent and two points secant
tangent have one very important property
let this be a circle and this are
tangent to it the radius to the point
where the circle and the tangent meet
will always be perpendicular to the
tangent so
a will be perpendicular to this tangent
no matter where the tangent is drawn the
radius to the point where it meets the
circle will always be perpendicular to
it there's another interesting concept
about tangents take a circle and an
external point P how many tangents can
be drawn from this point to the circle
we can draw one tangent like this and
another one like this two tangents can
be drawn from an external point to a
circle the interesting part is that both
these will be equal in length tangents
drawn from an external point to a circle
will be equal in length if the two
points at which the tangents meet the
circle are called a and B then we can be
sure that P a will be equal to P be in
length and if we draw the radii or a and
OB then we can be sure that o a will be
perpendicular to tangent B a and OB will
be perpendicular to tangent P B okay so
now we are ready to apply the concepts
we have learnt about tangents and
circles try solving this problem
so the first thing we are given is that
PA and PB are tangents to the circle we
are also told that the circumference of
this circle is 12 centimeters and the
two tangents form a 60 degree angle
between them how do we find the length
of Arc ACB this is fun how can we find
the length of this arc okay let's ask
ourselves another question what do we
need to find the length of this arc an
arc is simply a part of the
circumference so we need the
circumference and we are given that and
the length of the arc also depends on
the central angle it subtends so if we
draw radii or a and OB we get angle a or
B as the central angle of this arc but
we need the measure of this angle and we
haven't been given that can we find that
though let's see we know that the radio
to the points where the tangents meet
the circle are always perpendicular to
the tangents so both these angles will
be right angles now look at
quadrilateral PA OB this kite like water
lateral out of the four angles three
unknown to us and we can easily find the
fourth one with respect to this
quadrilateral we can say that 60 degrees
plus 90 degrees plus 90 degrees plus
angle AOB
will equal 360 degrees this gives us the
measure of angle AOB
as 120 degrees now we have everything we
need to calculate the length of the arc
if the central angle is Theta we note
that the length of Arc AC B will be
theta over 360 degrees times the
circumference which is 12 we substitute
120 in place of theta and get the length
of Arc ACB as 4 centimeters that's the
challenge we face in competitive exams
you may not be tested on just
one concept here we applied quite a few
some of angles of a quadrilateral length
of the arc formula and the concept of
radii perpendicular to the tangents